yeah if you take away the nerdum of it
all in the [ __ ] content houses like
just get to the point of it somebody got
groped while they would sleep and people
who had some power basically try to
cover it up that's the non-nerd version
but the reason why it needs all this
attention because all the personalities
surrounding it are nerds and it's like
high school
it's like it feels like high school okay
like that's what twitch is
yes which is is like is like high school
but with
uh
stars and virgins
that's what it is that's what twitch is
okay
so if you guys aren't aware twitch right
now is imploding okay they've had issues
about race they've had issues with
gambling and now their latest one some
of their biggest content creator uh and
the creator house have been covering up
what appears to be some sexual
you know i mean
some groping okay
some sexual what some sexual you know
what i mean okay
and that that that's literally what
happened okay i don't bear to work okay
you know but for this chapter
specifically it involves a few content
creators and some of the biggest one one
being miss kiff all right who's one of
the biggest content creators he runs a a
content home called otk along with
asthma gold and uh there's a lady named
maya and then there's another creator
named crazy slick
and lastly okay the one who deserves the
most amount of sympathy and no laughter
from you stop
is adriana lee
stop
bro you gotta think the more the more
you say stop the more i'm gonna stop
saying stop stop i'll try i'll try i
think it's important to learn how to say
stop and for you to listen
i'm sorry
yeah
yeah but we've been knowing i'm
problematic your purple bandana wearing
ass we weren't sure about i just want to
let them know we in the same boat it
really is i wouldn't preach
so basically what happened let's get
straight to it okay they have
these are all streamers they run a
content home they're all part of the
same home
she adrana lee is a young 20 year old
woman who moves to austin to be part of
this content home i think at the time
she might have been 18 when she moved at
the time of this incident um there's a
party at the house she goes there i
guess she drinks or something she passes
she falls asleep on the bed um there's a
bunch of folks around and this guy crazy
slick comes in and you know he'd been
hounding her the whole night but she
wasn't really down and then while she
was asleep apparently allegedly
according to multiple witnesses he went
and he grabbed
her titty
this comes out after the fact she finds
out and then this guy is denying it he
claims that he was checking her pulse
okay
this man
this man said he was checking her pulse
then go for the wrist then go for the
neck he said yo where her titties at and
i get it sometimes when i administer cpr
i go straight for the vagina we all do
things differently okay he went for the
titty to go check the secret that's what
his claim was
and then afterwards now they're saying
now he's saying no actually i never i
only went for her wrist and her neck but
multiple witnesses saw her go for the
titties saw him i yes okay
maya who helps run the home as well as
miss kiff um they found out about the
whole thing and basically they told
adriana like listen don't make it a big
thing keep it under wraps
you know you just keep it a little bit
that's the deal this is miss kip himself
speaking on the whole issue at the time
it happened okay like he he streamed
today at 10 in the morning and i bet you
he wasn't gonna he got up for 30 minutes
came downstairs and went back down like
just not hanging out dude
i haven't seen him in four days
i don't like to be alone all day
what's so slick what's slick being busy
with
being severely depressed
i mean he's been sleeping for 15 hours a
day
so this is him he's on stream right now
he's upset that he can't play with crazy
slick because he was being talked to at
the time and so this is what he said
about his thoughts
i told him i'm like look
you didn't anybody you know it's one
thing
he didn't do anything
and like people make it seem like he did
when people like think of it they think
that he stuck his [ __ ] inside her
i don't think there's a single person
that we used to hang out with that
doesn't hang out with slick anymore
because of what happened i actually
think there's literally none because the
reality is worse comes the worst of it
it's [ __ ] like sexual harassment
right
i mean like who get like
i mean like who get like
i mean like who get
he was about to say who the [ __ ] yes he
was gonna say that right he was about
this he wasn't go guard talk that talk
talk that [ __ ] he was about to say that
and then he
damn
dialed back yeah rephrasing something
else i don't think people really care
this is something that sounds good he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
no one
of what you can deem a bit it's sexual
harassment whatever
at a low scale it's not really a big
deal
when i hear the guy say
oh man i'm so sad i can't play with
crazy slick i miss playing video games
with my buddy this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's ice cream oh
oh he's not like he put his penis inside
or he's just he just grabbed her i don't
know what the [ __ ] is wrong in your head
bro i would literally never keep a
friend who's out here groping people in
their sleep i don't know what kind of
[ __ ] loser you are okay where you're
not only being okay with this behavior
from people you consider friends but
you're also actively trying to defend
you're a [ __ ] loser you're a [ __ ]
loser okay if you're at least trying to
work it out with him and figure it out
but don't try to downplay it
you know what i'm trying to say don't
try to downplay it the [ __ ] is
unconscious what you talking about
that's crazy that's correct no you can't
listen if i do send an awkward dm or
sends like a flirty message that's fine
she's unconscious and you out here
groping her and the fact that he lying
and doing all this defending you best
believe it's not this first time doing
weird [ __ ] yeah this video is brought to
you by surfshark hey sometimes you want
to watch certain videos from other
countries and you can because your
country is not allowed
i know well you need to get yourself a
vpn changer a vpn changer is something
that's going to change the location of
your computer i'm from canada and our
netflix is nice but it's not like the us
netflix or the uk netflix or any netflix
no or any netflix around the world and
sometimes i want to be able to enjoy
that content well i just teleport my
computer with the vpn changer wherever i
want it to be and i can enjoy
whatever
content i want and now if you if you go
on the link below you use the code abba
and preach you're going to be able to
save 83 and have three first month for
free i know i know go right now click on
the link below and you know
let your computer travel
and you will enjoy all the content that
you want
okay never happen
i mean it's still unfolding i mean you
know some of them came out statements
some of them said nothing one of the
co-organizers because um crazy slick the
one who did the groping
he came out and said allegedly
i would say allegedly normally the
problem is even the people who are
defending him said no he definitely put
his hands on her crazy slick
i was like i was just checking her pulse
i was checking her wrists even his
friends were defending him were like
listen what he did was clearly wrong
obviously so you get what i'm trying to
say he came out and said that and then
he deleted his tweet he said i
originally he said oh johnny depp
don't believe these women the same way
you guys shouldn't have believed amber
hurt against johnny depp like he tried
to make it a whole thing and so the
other owner of otk the house he came out
fair no you didn't you lying [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] you never got accused of
this is unfair i'll be getting a lawyer
as soon as possible learn from the
johnny depp situation and think first
last time i [ __ ] checked is you still
all have all ten fingers slick the [ __ ]
are you doing sitting around talking
about johnny depp you're going to use
his [ __ ] problem his thing where he
lost his [ __ ] finger he's got
marks on him everywhere he's got
10 years of us charges with different
witnesses and other people coming in
over and over and over and you have the
[ __ ] audacity to go in and use his
example to cover up for your slimy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
whether you touched her on the chest or
not you're a creepy [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] that uses your friends to go and
use act as a gatekeeper to keep people
out so you can allow yourself to be
[ __ ] abusive i [ __ ] hate you i
hope you die
i hope you [ __ ] die
god thank you
i do know some shamans in africa who do
voodoo if you're really interested in
that kind of behavior yeah if you take
away the nerdum of it all and the
[ __ ] content houses like just get to
the point of it somebody got groped
while they would sleep and people who
had some power basically try to cover it
up that's the non-nerd version what
should happen to that slick guy
well i mean listen as far as punishment
goes that's a tough one to say but what
he did was obviously criminal yeah but
it's too late to prosecute that now
probably i think what is really telling
though why is it too late is that it
happened when
two two years ago
absolutely unless he admits to it like
it's a very difficult thing and maybe
you can i don't think she's going to
because even if you do like what's the
worst
community service yeah it's a lot of
work all this to say
one thing i've noticed at least watching
this twitch stuff from outsider just
all these kinds of things like these
content houses these kinds of places
where creatives and people and power
exist you know people talk about
hollywood how gross it is but you
recognize that the same things that lead
to hollywood being gross are the same
thing that leads to most power
structures being grossed yeah you get
what i'm trying this is the ollie where
we really look at that at that hollywood
everyone watches we're really obsessed
with hollywood you know because everyone
watches movies but that [ __ ] happens
everywhere whether it's in school
whether it's
normal 9 5 7 11 or what not that [ __ ]
happens all the time i'm glad that i do
what i do on youtube i would not want to
be an environment like twitch i would
not want a body but buddy but you think
about it or come up we didn't have to do
a single collab with anybody the entire
time we didn't get shout outs from big
creators we didn't get no love we didn't
get no growth nothing and you know what
even though some people had some stuff
to say along the way it really didn't
matter because we could have just kept
going without it and they can keep
growing without us so that's the beauty
of being on this platform as compared to
other ones but we still don't need to
make we really make
collabs because we feel like kids yeah
or something that we it's people that we
were down with or people like like oh
i'm cool with that person we spoke a
couple of times yeah sure let's go let's
go do that or that would be interesting
but it's not like
a switch is like only fans what you mean
which means that sometimes you gotta
like whenever those are make that kind
of content on on only pants uh
only pants i'd like to say twitch is
kinda like only fans sometimes you gotta
get sometimes you got to bend over to
get ahead
that's not what i was about to say but i
mean you're not wrong man that's just
weird you're not wrong so in only fans
the thing that happens is that
sometimes you need to collab with other
people that do that and do that to get
ahead and just that so you get some of
their content creators and they get some
of the other you know what i mean so
it's kind of that that's why i say that
it's kind of the same thing yeah whereas
no you don't you know over here you
could do your merry thing and then
just do your thing in your niche you
know i mean and you know what i think
also is the thing
is a lot of the dudes that make it on
twitch i think why they always have a
lot of these scandals is a lot of the
dudes that make it on twitch are
socially awkward retards who have no
idea how to act around people and have
never really had attention and so all of
a sudden you're getting attention but
have zero people skills and all of a
sudden you're trying to figure out how
to navigate these spaces i'm not saying
this makes it okay or whatever that's
not my point my point is poor yeah
yeah
yeah it doesn't mean that you have to
write you never learn how to act you
never learn how to [ __ ] behave and
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
because a lot of weirdos doing a lot of
this [ __ ] on a smaller and larger scale
you guys ain't heard the stories yet so
me watching this unfold it's like
sounds like a cesspool
yeah yeah people like you know when
you're gonna get on twitch i'm like
[ __ ] never the thing is you'd be good
on twitch
this can't be but i don't think you'd
have this
uh
the stamina because the
that's yeah you wouldn't have
the not the moral stamina but the maybe
i like a balanced life i already do
youtube and stuff i'm not interested in
doing this [ __ ] but on the outside
watching in it's kind of cool for me
because i think i hate the platform just
because of like a lot of its political
stances and the way it kind of just
backs a bunch of losers
you know and so just seeing the fact
that
you know like they
here's an example
it's like these people will go out of
their way to prop up a bunch of like
trash behavior having creators like
hassanabe or miss kiff right
at the same time their biggest creator
on the platform right now is kaisenette
the young black kid who we covered a
while back i mean this is a separate
title i'll probably cover this another
time but
i don't know i just hate the platform
and what it stands for and how it's
really operated over time and so for me
to see it employed from the outside i'm
like good you know what i'm saying good
good maybe if you built a better
ecosystem that wasn't just so funneled
into having just a few content creators
be the biggest voices in owning
everything you might have some more
diversity of thought you might have more
people who are open to sharing their
opinions all the time and then also
calling out [ __ ] that's inappropriate
and then i think that would create for a
better world but i think but but because
you've like shut down a lot of that
growth and just made it one-dimensional
in a lot of ways people have to go
through these content houses people have
to do a lot of the [ __ ] in order to
get they don't have to it's a strong war
but very strongly are much more
incentivized to do so whereas on youtube
it's like if you want to avoid a lot of
that [ __ ] you can
you can and i'm grateful for that
because i'll be honest i would not be
here today if youtube ran itself like
twitch does there's no way i would have
done it not a [ __ ] chance you know as
a platform i hope it dies but that's my
thoughts this man really out here
defending the fact that his homies
groping women while they run that's fine
what do you think
that's not something that you do okay
that's
what i even have to comment on that is
that what we're doing yeah like what do
you think
like it's the obvious it's it's obvious
like someone is
i'm baffled by the question really yeah
like she's just there and that's that's
the thing is the whole setting you try
everybody saw you trying to get at her
the whole party
the whole party everybody's trying to
they saw you man what's up girl what's
up girl and she's like no no no no no
and then you're gonna go
and then you think it's all good while
she's sleeping yeah